cet hôtel est absolument exceptionnel
parce que vous n'avez pas d'équivalent
le dire pour le nord le nom au nord de
la loire
généralement au 17e c'est plutôt des
hôtels avec des factures ici on a un
hôtel de stuc
les villageois ont gardé l'hôtel tel
qu'il était à la fin du xviie siècle il
n'ya plus d'équivalent dans les églises
de l'île de france aujourd'hui
cet hôtel c'est l'un des joyaux de
l'église saint germain de paris qui lui
a valu son inscription au titre de
monument historique
une reconnaissance pour cet édifice du
12e siècle
magny les hameaux a oeuvré de 2002 à
2009 pour sa restauration
coût total des travaux 950 mille euros
financé à 80 % par la ville
beaucoup d'habitants tenait à ce que ce
ce lieu cette église soit préservée et
puis effectivement qu'on puisse avoir
une histoire la grande histoire de port
royal des champs et de magny les hameaux
côte à côte ont obtenu en novembre cette
distinction permettra de conserver au
mieux la mémoire locale
ce qui fait l'immense richesse de
l'église aujourd'hui à manille c'est
qu'elle conserve une quarantaine de
pierres tombales c'est la plus grosse
collection de tout le nord de la loire
dont 40 pierre tombale entre le xiiie
siècle et le xviie siècle dont les deux
tiers proviennent de l'abbaye de port
royal
autre découverte ce tableau du xviie
siècle du peintre italien guido reni
saint jérôme au désert une seule
réplique existe à la national gallery de
londres
l'église du village n'a pas fini de
dévoiler tous ses secrets